。
借着这部电影，我给你找的这14个方法，以及给你举的例子，你再去看其他喜剧电影往里填。我保证你你在喜剧这条路上能够领先绝大多数人。我们来说一下这部片子为什么分不高啊，当然与它是呃穿越喜剧是有关系的啊，大家对穿越喜剧先天的一个基础基基础基本分给的就比较低。
啊，为什么呢？强设定呀不现实呀，会觉得有点赖呀，强设定这是第一这是第一。第二呢，由于这部片子它本身是个穿越型的。
抢喜剧。按理说呢，你应该往回搂一搂啊，比如说你应该像那种难兄难弟啊，你好李焕英啊那种戏，用真诚的感情往回搂一搂。但这个戏呢反其道而行之，不光不往回搂，还弄了很多的蒙太奇，弄了很多的一剪眉，弄了很多的很夸张，可气啊就是。
已经不真实了，还要再往不真实那条路上再争吧争吧。同学们理解我在说什么吗？一般来说啊，咱们在创作一个戏的时候，如果这个戏已经含有让人容易有点出戏的不真实的强设定。我们会在其他方面进行一些弥补。比如说啊会做一点比较真挚的感情。
比较这种呃会少用一些漫画感的东西。我们说啊蒙太奇的剪辑啊，就是很多漫画感的东西啊，在这部电影呢，人家完全没有回避啊，就跟你玩到底。这个呢确实就造就了一部分人不会呃就不喜欢给他打高分啊。因为我刚才说过啊，有很多人总以为呃这个现实啊，真实呀会比较高级啊。那我我不否定这部分同学的观点啊，因为。
这不是你自己的观点，很多人都这么认为啊，我只是把这个情况给大家展现出来，你们啊你们自己去品味啊，自己去选择。我们再来说一下这部戏啊，为什么说这个蒙太奇为什么这个确实多了一点啊，因为确实人家以歌曲啊以歌曲为为一个重要元素，这个呢就难免啊歌曲为重要元素的话，再加上他正好伙伴也比较多，伙伴设计的也比较出彩啊。
所以说做做了这种这种蒙太奇的剪辑就会相对多一些啊，这个我们也要理解一下，我们再来思考一个问题啊，就是这个故事啊对手普遍不太强啊，那怎么来处理呢？就是拆解啊，我们说一下这个片子如愿以偿这个故事啊，先学习一下如愿以偿类型故事的写法以后也要学会啊。
大概分这么几个阶段啊。第一。
对现实不满啊，现实要有明确的不满。
然后呢。
说出自己的愿望啊，把它说出来，把咒语说出来，然后呢实现这个愿望，实现这个愿望啊，实现愿望在故事的中前部在追寻外部目标的同时获得爽感啊。然后呢遭遇打击之后，情况急转直下，然后来付出代价，然后最终呢回归现实，发现眼珍惜眼前或者珍前珍惜当前的生活。
我们说这个流程我们其实是比较熟悉的啊，我们在讲如愿以偿这种类型的时候，已经讲的比较明确了，基本上都是这么个流程啊，我们可以扩展的去看一下重返17岁，或者是梁朝伟、梁家辉的难兄难弟啊。这几部电影大家可以去看一下呃，扩展阅读啊，对手不太强是这类喜剧题材的通病啊。我们说这部戏的主要对手是圆滑啊。
圆华如果一直捣乱，那这部片子喜剧就会大打折扣，明白吗？所以说我们把它拆解开了，对吧？其使对手是老师，然后后来呢是马冬梅，对吧？他要追求秋雅，先要过老师这一关，后来又要过马冬梅这一关。再后来呢再后来过圆华这一关，然后到后面他要开始追求马冬梅了，又要过大春这一关，对不对？
所以说他其实是把对手拆解了。但是我在这里其实我要提出一个问题，咱们如果同学写这个电影啊，假设我们没有看过夏洛特话呢，我们脑子里面没有这个概念啊，只有这么一个创意，说我们一个呃一个一个角色要穿越回高中时候啊追求不起追求这个。
自己的。
呃，女神重新来过，我们很有可能把本能的主要对手或者是主很多的篇幅会给到老师和校长。同学们，你们再想想，如果我们。
接手的这个项目。
没有。
没有束缚，也没有参考。
我们很有可能把很多篇幅，把很多对抗给到老师，给到校长，还有父母就会很本能的写这些。但是我想告诉大家是，写那些也没有错，你不用担心你做错了，你这么想没有错。那这部戏为什么把对手集中在同班的这些伙伴身上了呢？
我们要知其然知其所以然呀，不要无脑吹，也不要无脑黑，因为它是话剧改的，他是就着前面这场婚礼。
因因为因为话剧就那几场戏，参加婚礼的这帮同学待会还得用。
不要每次都觉得有什么高深的道理。我告诉你，你穿越回去本能的写老师的戏，本能的写家长的戏，本能的写校长的戏是很正确的。你没想错，所有同学。
接下来。
所有同学啊记笔记这个电影我们学我们最重要的要学的东西，你可以不喜欢这个电影的主题，不喜欢这个电影的人设，不喜欢这个电影的风格，不喜欢这个电影的画面，不喜欢这个电影的节奏。但是我们必须承认它的笑点是真的多呀。
通过这节课，我们记一下他一共用了多少种笑点创作方式。
你给我记笔记，我们当然知道人家是通过几百场的话剧给磨出来的，磨出来这么多笑点。
但是咱们集中学习一下，不就胜读十年书吗？开始记笔记这个电影。
都用了哪些笑点创作方式？第一种。
爽子。
必然有我们说开挂的东西都有爽感。
我们说开挂的东西啊都有爽感，也就是信息差。比如说。
比如说他一路开挂，唱别人的歌就可以红，我们是不是笑了？
他告诉大春，你要买房，你得买房，买二环以内的房，我们是不是笑了？
我们为什么笑了？
因为我们跟主角一样，享受着了这个开挂的爽感，包括出来什么周杰伦啊，你说相约酒吧这首歌好笑吗？他跟大英唱相约酒吧，我们是不是笑了，知道爽感啊，爽感可以让人发笑，爽感可以让人发笑啊，这是这部电影最重要的一个笑点，我们把它排在第一个后面的顺序不分先后，你自己去记，自己去研究。
第二种创造呃那个笑点的方法，误会。
误会是喜剧常用套路。在这个电影里当然也没有，并没有缺席，人家也用了啊。比如说把马冬梅当成秋雅，是不是误会啊？马冬梅把自己当成落嫂，是不是误会啊？大春以为马冬梅把剩剩剩的面汤当成马当马冬梅给她做的茴香汤，你笑了没有啊？
诶，这是茴香汤喝了，你是不是笑了，误会又是一种。
来第三种荒诞。
啊，荒诞荒诞是什么呢？就是无厘头啊，无厘头。比如说妈妈和张扬结婚对吧？哥找什么呢？爸帮你找找啊。我们说虽然是台词性笑点，但是他是基于荒诞，其实就是基于有点无厘头啊，包括我曾经说过的那个指路的那个大爷，其实他很荒诞啊，无厘头。
指路的那个大爷很荒诞啊，很无厘头，明白吗？他明明认识马冬梅，什么冬梅什么马马什么梅荒诞啊，第4个。
讽刺比如说啊老师收礼其实并不是一个让人开心的事情吧。
那我们笑了没有啊，你送的收音机，你送的电视机，老师，我们家送的挂历。
那我就不记得了是吧？老师不记仇。
是不是讽讽刺讽刺各种广告，讽刺区长父亲是吧？讽刺官僚，讽刺小舅子抱富婆。我们说这种情况本来就是社会阴暗面啊，本来就是社会阴暗面。我们是不是笑了？那我们为什么笑了？
老师收礼这件事情其实本来不好笑。那我们为什么笑呢？
这不也是穿越系带来的优势吗？距离感明白吗？距离感就是这件事情本身是丑恶的。如果是20多年以前的事情，我们会会笑。因为有距离感，笑是要保持距离感的。如果你你你你现在遇到一个老师收礼，你你能笑得出来吗？你笑不出来呀，对不对？对吧？所以说这是讽刺。
这节课最大的收获在这里我都帮你们总结好了。如果你们还不好好记笔记，你们就是真傻。第五种，冒犯，我们说讽刺是讽刺不好的东西啊。
讽刺是讽刺不好的东西，但是冒犯却是冒犯的一一群冒犯。
弱势群体其实还好，我们说娘炮孟特娇对吧？他很娘，我们是不是笑了？孟特娇很娘孟特最后变性成了孟特娇，我们是不是笑人家了，是吧？冒犯啊冒犯包括大傻春是吧？大傻春一直很傻啊，这不就是冒犯嘛？笨一点而已吗？
冒犯人家哎，少用这个同学说的非常对啊，少用啊。其实以后咱们真的少用。你包括梦特和梦特娇这个梗呢，我其实是不提倡用的啊，不提倡用，有点冒犯。因为太老了，那是50年前的老黄历了，现在最好就别用了啊，最好就别用了。来第六种啊呼应呼应。比如说哎呼应叫ca back，记得吧。
call back记得吧？比如说两次赋尸对吧？马冬梅的拔罐子啊，包括他妈妈的死，对吧？你不知道你是怎么死吗？这种前后呼应啊，我们说这个callback啊也会引发我们的会心一笑啊，而且我们还会觉得哎我记得之前有这个情节，哎，又来了，还会觉得挺过瘾的call back啊，来第七，我不知道说到第几个了啊，共情。
大家自己记啊，共情共情为什么也会引发我们的共会心一笑呢？是因为我们有有共同的美好回忆，比如说偷抽烟呀。
比如说给别人这个自行车锁上呀，比如偷偷看黄色图片呀。
比如穿校服，喜欢把领子立起来呀，对吧？校服套校服呀。我们说这些是我们小时候我们小时候。
认知过的。
但是呢我们会产生共情。
也会让我们会心一笑。有个同学说，基本原理好像都是打破不有认知。不是你要你往一块总结，那我告诉你，基本原理都是建立优越感，那你就啥也学不着了。你往一块总结说，让别人笑的基本原理就是你要写的好笑，你要是非要一条总结出来，那咱也不用分解了，那你能写出来吗？下一个恶搞经典。
恶搞经典，比如说一剪梅啊，一剪梅这个就是标准的恶搞经典。
我们对。
对这个恶搞经典呃，对一剪梅或者对当年的那些言情偶像剧是有是有刻刻板印象。比如说咱们其实对琼瑶剧也有刻板印象，像我们说这种啊都属于恶搞经典啊，是挺有意思的啊，挺有意思。
下一个还是说啊排名不分先后啊，你们自己记就行了，能记多少，记多少谐音梗俏皮画他们也没少用啊。大家想一想，下落不明是吧？马冬梅是吧？各种谐音梗，各种俏皮画，再下一个啊，模仿啊模仿我们说模仿那个刘欢是吧？模仿那个周周杰伦是吧？模呃模仿那个中国好声音。
模仿在最早的喜剧里面，最早的滑稽戏里面是不可或缺的。我们说在最早的舞台滑稽戏里面，模仿秀永远是不可或缺的，对吧？你能活灵活现的模仿大英，活灵活现的模仿刘欢，大家也会会会心一笑啊，模仿啊模仿因为这不既不讽刺，也不冒犯，就是单纯模仿你就能笑。下一个又是一个常用的手法。
比如说一个人力气特别大，嗓门特别大是吧？魅力特别大，别人别人看到他就晕倒，夸张啊，夸张是创造笑点的前几位的常用手段。夸张在周星驰的电影里面用的多，周星驰喜欢用夸张和荒诞，其实也就是夸张和无厘头啊。这个大家记着每个人喜欢用的东西不多啊，喜欢用的东西呃就是比较固定。
下一个。
现实报，我们看到现实报也容易笑啊。比如说那个大爷被泼了一口水是吧？那个校长被人整是吧？老师被蒙蒙着蒙起来打是吧？现实暴就这个人呢。
这瑟大劲儿了，显示报。
我们也是愿意笑的啊，来下一个动作性笑点，什么摔倒呀是吧？崴脚呀，不会走路呀，不会骑车呀，被烫着呀。
呀被砸着呀。
动作型笑点也是支柱之一。然后最后一个。
也是常用的巧合。
我们说这个故事没人巧合啊，我能想我能记着的啊。比如说夏洛来找马冬梅，然后想要其实是想要找马冬梅复合。然后嘞，大春回来说，哎，我刚才买了几顶帽子都是我喜欢的颜色，全是绿帽子。
巧合是吧？这有多少个了，十来个吧？当然了，不是严格的分类啊，就是给大家启发一下创作喜剧。同学们，这些东西在别的地方，咱们就很难一次性的总结这么多。基于这节课，基于这部电影，咱们一下学这么多。你把这14个记下来，然后再去看几个喜剧电影给我往里填，你借着这部电影，我给你找的这14个方法以及给你举的例子，你再去看其他喜剧电影往里填。
我保证你你在喜剧这条路上能够领先绝大多数人。因为你像牛逼如周星驰，他也只用几个方法，他也只不过是特别喜欢用荒诞，特别喜欢用夸张。
对不对？它俏皮话基本不太用吧，模仿也基本不太用吧啊，当然动作会用啊，动作会用，巧合也不太用吧，啊，是不是啊？
共情也不太用吧。
howllback也不太用吧，是吧？所以说我当然了，你也可以有所侧重，不可能全都擅长。这部电影为什么这么奇？咱们讲一遍，这部电影为什么这么奇啊？是因为它是几百场话剧集体创作下来，就这么简单，他不是一个人一两个人写的，一两个人写不可能写这么齐的，一两个人写也会有偏好的。
为什么咱们一定要讲这部电影？如果选别的喜剧电影，它往往是几个人创作的那他肯定没有那么全。这部电影咱们能够一次性学全所有的喜剧总的创作方法，你别管了人家创作的好不好，咱肯定学全了，咱肯定学全了。
这节课我想给大家讲的最重要的事情就是这件事情。这节课咱们也讲的时间也特别长，为什么多花点时间给大家讲呢？喜剧啊，大赛道啊，好不好？学一学喜剧好不好？你会写喜剧啊，在这这这个市场上绝对是能够占得先机。
那咱们今天啊就讲这么多啊，这是最重要的一件事情。大家自己去记一下。有个同学说，如果马冬梅在小树林里不是打伤了对方，而是被对方给玷污了，会不会烈度更高一点，那肯定呀。但是喜剧感就少了嘛。因为如果被玷污了，我们后面就很难笑出来了。从现实主义题材的角度来讲，其实是会更好。
我承认。
但是嘞后面就不太会笑了，咱们就很难笑出来了。
马冬梅和夏洛算伙伴之情吗？在这个戏里面并不算呀。
他是他是目标呀，在这个戏里面没有展现他两个人相爱的过程呀。人家是展现是作为目标呀。有的同学说每节课感觉收获很大，那不废话吗？咱们讲课是来干嘛的，对不对？你可以怀疑我的人品，甚至可以怀疑我的长相，但是不要怀疑老师给你讲的课。
懂不懂啊？年级你可以怀疑所有的东西，但是我讲的课我不容许任何人怀疑说查理老师讲的课不行，或者查理老师课没有成过，这个就吹牛逼了。他一共用了多少种笑点创作方式？第一种爽感。
必然有我们说开挂的东西都有爽感。比如说他一路开挂唱别人的歌就可以红。他告诉大春，你要买房买二环以内的房，我们为什么笑要呢？因为我们跟主角一样，享受着了这个开挂的爽感。第二种误会误会是喜剧常用套路。
比如说把马冬梅当成秋雅，马冬梅把自己当成落草，是不是误会啊？第三种荒诞就是无厘头啊，无厘头。比如说妈妈和张扬结婚，哥找什么呢？爸帮你找找啊，必然是台词性笑点。第四个嗯次，老师收礼你送的收音机，你送的电视机。
老师，我们家送的惯例，那我就不记得了，是吧？老师不记仇，是不是讽刺讽刺区长父亲本来就是社会阴暗面啊，但我们为什么笑了？这不也是穿越西带来的优势嘛？所以有距离感，要是要保持距离感的。所以说这是讽刺。第五种冒犯，讽刺是讽刺不好。
但是冒犯却是冒犯的一一群梦特娇很娘梦特，最后变性成了梦特娇，我们是不是笑人家了？那这个梗啊，我其实是不提倡用的啊，因太老了。第六种啊呼应。比如说两次赋尸马冬梅的拔罐子用前后呼应也会引发我们的。
会心一笑啊，第七，共情是因为我们也有共同的美好回忆。比如说偷抽烟呀，比如穿校服，喜欢把领子立起来呀，这些是我们小时候认知过的，我们会产生共情，也会让我们会心一笑。恶搞经典，我们对一剪梅或者对当年的那些言情偶像剧。
他们其实对琼瑶剧也有刻板印象，就这种啊都属于恶搞经典谐音梗俏皮画大落不明，是吧？马冬梅是吧？各种谐音梗，各种俏皮画是吧？模仿啊，模仿模仿那个刘欢是吧？模仿那个中。
周杰伦呃，中国好声音模仿在最早的喜剧里面不可或缺的夸张。比如说一个人力气特别大，毅力特别大，，别人看到他就晕倒，夸张是创造笑点的常用手段啊，现实暴。比如说那个大爷被泼了一口水啊，老师被蒙起来打。
我们也是愿意笑的啊，动作型笑点什么摔倒呀、崴脚呀、动作型笑点也是知柱之一。巧合夏洛来找马冬梅想，其实是想要找马冬梅复合。大春回来说，哎，我刚才买了几顶帽子都是我喜欢的颜色，全是绿帽子。
还是巧合。
。